[Music]
in fight would be killed news o
submitted by was good Bart okay forget
all of us
thanks UFC world champ Michael visiting
refused to sign a new contract because
his management threatened to kill him
whoa that's forgetting so [ __ ] crazy
look like death row where the management
was like I'll [ __ ] kill you if you
don't find this and we'll [ __ ] else I
won't sign it kill me like that
just kill me to kill me I mean pretty
much like there's writing it was like
you know you've ever signed this or we
will kill you but like he's refusing
Simon conjurer who don't kill me I kill
me is that what he says who is his
management
what's his management company gangster
gangster inks and I did Suge Knight for
all it seems like there was two
different kinds of management's involved
so one was the wolf Slayer MMA gym and
the other one is his former manager and
named Anthony looking so Anthony is the
one that's trying to sue Michael for
$350,000 and he's trying to kill him
well I mean he's training him in that
sense yeah what I'm so confused
so mine because if you kill him you're
not going to get any money or maybe it's
just like those fleeting threats like
it's not a real threat like I'm gonna
[ __ ] kill you I mean like there
wasn't any actual hits out against
Michael like to actually try to kill him
yeah you can't say something like at all
you didn't so it comes from Michael's
own testimony it was saying like when I
was given a new contract I refused to
sign it they said like don't try to kill
me I'm soaked in my new contract but
it's also like over the years of threats
- so like during his contract with his
manager and with this gym apparently
like whenever he like participated in
two competitions and stuff you know like
they would get like percentage
Commission right and so whenever they
get the money from the fight Michaels
claiming that he never received any of
his money or like that they took an
absurd that's all super-shady yes and so
the what's happening right now is that
this
manager he's doing Michael for $350,000
because he was just saying like well I
mean during those six years of us like
hosting you like you know you got to pay
up your feet right and so Michael was
like well I don't remember signing a
contract with you Anthony I am ever
signing a contract with the gym right it
was like I had a conscience with the gym
saying that like I would be doing this
and I did pay off the seeds of whatever
I had to pay off to that right now he's
just taking up a stance and like I want
my money like it's not fair like I've
been threatening will saying that
Michael say matters matters man Michael
Michael saying that this is crazy the
manager in court actually brought up
like the actual conch like a contract
which we don't know if it's like the
actual contract or if it's like a fake
contract because what Michael is saying
is like well hey look that is my
signature on this contract what the
thing is though I remember this contract
had less pages you've got the last page
and he added a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ]
into it probably really weird you know
what America you initial every other
page in between I don't know how they do
it over there and freaking Zimbabwe then
over here we initial every single page
between /li has to have a copy of the
contracts himself all signing party
should have like the original Georgia
that's what I was thinking so when the
question was brought up from Anthony's
lawyer asking Michael so you know if
Anthony was supposedly threatening you
of after all these years how come you
never report it and right now he's gonna
that [ __ ] that's what he says and so
Michael was just like well I mean there
was no point in bringing it up you know
I thought I was just moving on the
pictures were up I didn't have to deal
with any more Dannan is a hard case I
just can't believe a regular person is
threatening an MMA fighter I would never
say anything like that maybe he's not
regular maybe he's a thug alright
possible but it's also you're not
dealing with rappers you're dealing with
the actual killer so it's a little bit
different it's like how you gonna
threaten a Navy SEAL
I'm achillea to actually know I kill
people so I'll kill you
and so for Michaels offense he was just
saying you know what all these Breton
I've been given over the past years like
I would say is a breach of my contract
especially since you've been like swing
away money from me as well - so shady
and I'm hard there's so much shady of
entertainment there is it happens all
the time with managers always stealing
money from their clients so scary
dori of no Alanis Morisette has a story
though sometimes I get nervous if like
I'm being taken advantage I don't really
know a lot of things about finances and
then that's where it is it's it's the
lack of knowledge on like so like Loras
will Japp upon contract and that they're
just the lingo if you're charging yeah
the jargon is just so like you can't
understand it unless you have something
purpose it's like an enigma right you
got a decode it if you want to
understand what is and that's the point
to confuse you long enough for you to
just be gonna sign something that's why
you just got to get a lawyer you know
what the scary part of that is so
someone hits you with the contract right
and then your idea protect myself so I
got to get a lawyer then your lawyer
hits you with the contract between you
and him so you're like do I need to get
another lawyer face and but doesn't get
out of contract which is like there's
all these contracts and all these people
in here it's like [ __ ] why don't you
guys just write your normal a ping
glitch why can't we just shake hands and
say agree yeah if one of you guys [ __ ]
us over I'll kill you but we have to be
one of these champagne shake so
likelihood the Sam heck yeah agreed
agreed
I'll trade you my daughter for three
goats a Viking pancake pancake perfect
Sam shaken hands on her and pancake
pancake pan shake what the [ __ ] is
happening over there
Vikings corduroy pancakes I think that's
what needs to happen there's this
contract that Anthony presented in court
Michael looked at it it was like okay
well okay granted I didn't read the full
contract all not my signature but like I
didn't read the full contract
I remember that there's less pages in
there should never say that and then
saying at the time he said to me sign it
if it's not fair that it won't stand up
in court
that was his advice whoa so I thought
that I know unfortunately like that's
why he messed up and so at that time
like when he sided conscious he just
signed it based off of what I think
that's why a lot of entertainers get but
they don't most of us don't give a damn
about business we don't even want to
know it just lets you hurting our heads
so it's like I got just whatever it
takes to get away now I'm going to be
but it just comes with the territory and
people need to understand it you know
I'm like no I'm not to take you more
than you though yeah honestly that's
true that's why I'm taking karate
lessons whatever is still at the
business thing I'm just going to do the
posse you want to give me a shitty
contract guess what I know karate but
martial arts doesn't let me beat your
ass so guess what it's useless
and then even brought up the fact that
like this this part was shady cuz he was
saying that in court they started
talking about timesheets and he's never
heard about like timesheets at it in a
gym and like he was saying like this is
like all lies in this fabrication
oh they were saying he was like on a
time she never showed up and said I
never clocked in or clocked oh yeah like
there was no record of that like they
never enforce anything like that before
and now they're bringing it up in court
like what is like them shady people are
[ __ ] shady tell me the system is off
to win you know I mean that's terrible
but so what Michaels trying to do is
that he's getting this like professional
signature reader or like handwriting
reader to see if like his signature on
the contract that's in the court as
evidence if it's actually like like his
signature or feel like somebody like a
copy did or [ __ ] over well with him
saying like I didn't really read the
contract like you already like sold
yourself to the jail he's done why don't
we just open a ninja and go over to the
the Anthony guys places be that man what
if this happened in advance
like if you don't dance again we're
gonna freakin kill you
honestly I don't doubt that elements of
that do happen maybe it might not be
killed maybe it so I don't break your
ankle so you never dance again oh no
that is your moneymaker yeah the ankles
specifically no ankles you're done just
sayin I repeat when it comes to like any
concept like that especially in
entertainment right there's always like
a different like you look I think we
talked about this before you look at
like the major athletes or anything like
that and there's still all the other
people that go around that person right
the person signing a person has checked
the management the families like so many
people anybody that can grab a chunk of
this person's money fame or success or
whatever that's capable of doing it
they'll tradition themselves in such a
way that they'll allow them to do that
you know what I mean
whether it's like not signing the prenup
to you know to be not like explaining
that jargon to to the person you're
managing because like you okay don't
worry about you play your game and I'll
handle this for you
can I tell you something really
personally that's the reason why Jake he
just doesn't want to blow up like we
like we just want a bomb just kidding I
was just thinking Gio shut the [ __ ] up
because I don't know where you come up
with that we don't work I don't want to
leave you know okay where's my [ __ ]
movie this window me please
we're trying to prove the money it is
just so much coming at it you know that
we're just it's like I don't know that
jargon if there's anybody out there who
wants to take advantage of me it's like
it'll be so easy
I saw everything so lines of mail me we
do it to ourselves we do it to ourselves
I mean like think about it man everybody
gets sponsored by so-called company
angry with [ __ ] em I'm starting with
em ends with s big arches right big
[ __ ] golden arches everybody around
us we don't Airlines everybody we know
it's almost like they specifically know
who we are and they do their best to
[ __ ] sponsor everybody around us maybe
a big-ass prank it is like a reverse
measurement show and then you're finally
going to get the sponsorships know what
we need to do is ever
one that we bring on to the show that
gets that we get a cut because it's cut
off it's because of it so pay off in a
good path right now okay guys I hope you
enjoyed that episode of just kidding
news and if you guys want to share a
story there's a link down in the
description box below where you can
submit your story if you guys want to
watch more episodes click right up here
[Applause]